convierte las siguientes ecuaciones
lineales en la forma pendiente ordenada
de origen pendiente ordenada al origen y
después gráfica las en el mismo plano
cartesiano y bueno sería bastante útil
recordar que es la forma pendiente
ordenar el origen y la forma de
pendiente ordenar el origen se ve más o
menos así y es igual a mx más fe donde m
es la pendiente y b es la ordenada al
origen es decir donde interceptamos al
eje de las 10 y por lo tanto pues
empecemos con la línea a la línea a es 4
x + 2 e igual a menos 8 4 x + 2 de igual
a menos 8 y bueno lo que tengo que hacer
es despejar al ayer por lo tanto lo
primero que voy a hacer es pasar este 4x
del otro lado de la ecuación y para eso
voy a restar 4x de ambos lados de la
ecuación y que me va a quedar bueno del
lado izquierdo esté 4x y este 4x se van
sinde sencillamente se cancelan y me
queda 2 james y del lado derecho me va a
quedar menos 8 menos 4 x esto es lo
mismo que menos 4 x menos 8
y menos 4 x menos 8 o menos 8 menos 4 x
es exactamente lo mismo y bueno ahora
para despejar allí lo que me estorba
este 2 por lo tanto voy a dividir ambos
lados de una ecuación entre 2 así que
voy a dividir tanto el lado izquierdo
como el lado derecho entre 2 y que me va
a quedar aquí entre 2 y del lado derecho
esté entre 2 y esté entre 2 cada uno de
los términos de mi lado derecho los voy
a dividir entre 2 y bueno 2 y 2 se van y
me queda que james es igual a menos 4
entre 2 lo cual es menos 2 x menos 8
entre 2 lo cual es menos 4 menos 4 y ya
está ya tengo en la ecuación ha visto
como una recta de la forma pendiente
ordenada al origen y ya que tengo mi
respuesta ahora lo que tengo que hacer
es graficar la en este plano cartesiano
y lo primero lo que me fijo es en la
ordenada al origen es decir en donde
interceptamos al eje de las 10 que
interceptamos el eje de las 10 en menos
4 es decir justo aquí aquí tengo mi
primer punto que es el cero como -4 y a
partir de aquí voy a graficar esta línea
recta porque tengo una
de -2 eso qué quiere decir que cuando yo
camino uno horizontalmente tengo que
bajar dos verticalmente cuando cambiamos
en x una unidad cambiamos en dos
unidades hacia abajo una unidad dos
unidades hacia abajo y tengo este punto
o por ejemplo si yo cambio dos unidades
en x pues tendré que bajar cuatro
unidades en bien tengo este otro punto y
de igual manera para cambios negativos
en x cuando yo voy de manera horizontal
pero hacia la izquierda entonces tengo
que subir 2 porque entonces no va a
quedar dos positivos en yemen entre
menos uno en x y tengo en la misma
pendiente y de igual manera si cambio
dos negativos en x tengo que subir
cuatro en bien y ya que tengo esto
entonces ahora déjenme graficar esta
línea recta y se va a ver más o menos
así es un trabajo decente para decir que
esta es la gráfica de mi ecuación
o de mi recta a y bueno pues ahora vamos
a ver qué es lo que pasa con ver el
inciso b dice 4x es igual a menos 84 x
es igual a menos 8 y según
es decir y cómo puedo poner esto en la
forma pendiente ordenada al origen yo no
veo ningún ayer y te voy a responder no
es necesario tener allí de hecho esto lo
podemos simplificar un poco dividiendo
todo entre 4 y me va a quedar entre 4
entre 4 el 444 se cancela y esto es lo
mismo que x igual a menos 2 y esta es
una recta constante no importa cuánto
valga james x siempre va a valer menos 2
entonces si aquí está x igual a menos 2
no importa cuánto valga james x siempre
va a valer menos 2 así que dejamos
graficar los lo mejor posible por aquí y
para abajo también x siempre va a valer
menos 2 y bueno claro había olvidado que
este es el eje de las equis y este es el
eje de las 10 así que vamos a ver qué
pasa con la línea c la línea se que nos
dicen 2 y es igual a menos 8 así que lo
primero que voy a hacer es dividir ambos
lados de esta igualdad entre dos y me
queda que james 2 y 2 se van y es igual
a menos 4 y qué creés ésta también es
una recta constante aquí no está
diciendo que quiere siempre vale menos 4
más
lo que pase en x valga lo que valga en x
que siempre vale menos 4 o dicho de otra
manera lo podemos ver así y es igual a 0
x
4 entonces nuestra ordenada de origen
sería menos 4 que es justo este mismo de
aquí y este de aquí es menos 4 y nuestra
pendiente es de cero es decir no cambia
si nosotros cambiamos 1 en x pues ya no
cambia si nosotros tenemos 2 en x ya
tampoco cambia o cambia a ser unidades
por lo tanto nos mantenemos en esta
línea recta que estoy dibujando justo
aquí es decir estamos fijándonos en la
recta que es igual a menos 4 el inciso
cm y perfecto lo hemos logrado